hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of stuff happened on arrow tonight
and we have a trailer for the vigilante
episode so because there's so much
comic-book stuff happening I'm gonna
combine these two videos so I'm gonna
start with the trailer for vigilante but
we may have found out who prometheus is
on arrow
they're definitely leading us around
with the way they're dropping clues so
obviously spoilers for episode 6 here we
go we are fighting a war on two fronts
these murders might be the works of a
different vigilante we're on the same
side stop trying to kill us
a job done this is a war but I'm gonna
fight it the right way as I am all this
city has so just to address that trailer
footage that is the vigilante character
right out of the comics he's basically
the district attorney taking on a
vigilante persona because as he says in
the trailer you're not getting the job
done this is a war Oliver feels like
he's gone completely crazy like they
just had this big thing in episode 6
with Oliver's list and him being a
serial killer in the first season his
realization the killing is not supposed
to be the first option but you have the
district attorney who just completely
loses his [ __ ] so Oliver obviously wants
to shut him down before he causes more
damage so that'll be a really awesome
fight I'll be interested to see where
they take it because in the comics like
he's actually a good person who goes
crazy because his family is killed so
we'll see how close they keep it to the
comic book store in next week's episode
but it's getting really crazy on arrow
if you couldn't tell from this episode
they are ramping up to the mid-season
finale for Knight crossover 100th
episode in the mid-season finale which
is nothing to say for what they're
introducing in episode 10 Talia al Ghul
and Laurel both coming back but now they
haven't explained how Laurel is coming
back but just the idea the two huge
things are happening in episode 10
before we even know what the plot is
gonna be but that's the thing I think
there's a big twist with the Prometheus
reveal at the end of episode 6 so just
to start with the biggest stuff first
they found out the Prometheus is someone
inside the police station or someone
with access to the police station and
they want you to think that it's Quentin
because he has a cut on his arm the same
place that Prometheus was cut by Artemis
and he has one of the throwing stars but
because he's been getting blackout drunk
or seemingly blackout drunk that's why
he has the look on his face like he
doesn't recognize what's going on he's
like why is my arm cut what is this
crazy throwing star so very clearly
something is happening when Quentin is
getting blackout drunk so someone might
be manipulating him and that might have
something to do with Talia al Ghul
this season but remains to be seen I
want to point something out though
before we talk about Dolph Lundgren
though because that was the other huge
thing I really loved his introduction
scene is that there was a big twist in a
Batman animated movie called mystery of
the Batwoman
where Batman finds out that there's this
bat woman running around the city being
a vigilante but then he finds out that
it's actually three women pretending to
be one person so just because they're
pointing you in the direction of a
couple different Prometheus people
doesn't mean it has to be a single
person because we've only heard
Prometheus talk a few times like when he
was in a subway car he didn't say
anything at all and you don't get a good
sense for how tall he is people think
that it might be Felicity's boyfriend he
seemed genuinely excited when Felicity
revealed she was working with the green
arrow he did ask her all those questions
so I know that seems kind of weird but
the way he was playing it like I'm
guessing that the Billy Malone character
is not an amazing actor otherwise he's
turning in an oscar-worthy performance
pulling the wool over Felicity's eyes
like oh wow who's the green arrow do you
know where he lives when we literally
just heard Tobias church reveal to
Prometheus that it was Oliver Queen in
god zero reaction meaning that
Prometheus already knew who Oliver Queen
was and Prometheus knows about the list
there aren't that many people that know
about Oliver's list they would have had
to have been around during season 1 or
been someone else who had access to
another list because you're talking
about people that were in league with
Merlyn because like Oliver's mother for
example knew about the list when
Oliver's father separate from his mother
gave Oliver his copy of the list
so there are a handful of people that
know about the list especially people
that were around for original team arrow
which does include Quentin so Quentin
definitely checks a lot of boxes when it
comes to who prometheus might be but the
thing is is that he clearly does not
realize what's going on
so one either someone is mind
controlling him somehow when he gets
blackout drunk because there's no way
he'd be able to fight when he was
actually blackout drunk something has to
be going on it's not so simple like it's
not just like a reverse Green Arrow
where somebody takes up the cause there
is very clearly a conspiracy at work
trying to pin this on Quentin because
Paul Blackthorne himself is actually a
pretty fit person so he could pull off
stunts like that now they probably do
have a stunt person when they do big
fight scenes but Paul Blackthorne
himself could actually double as
Prometheus he's the right size he's
actually taller than Stephen Amell he's
about six four
Stephen Amell is only about 6 1 so
Prometheus does seem like a big guy so
it could be him
underneath the mask but the thing is is
that it all goes back to mind control
because otherwise how would Quentin not
realize what's going on when he wakes up
like in this drunken stupor and sees the
cut on his arm and sees one of
Prometheus as throwing stars so because
there's still so much information that
we don't know yet I feel like the
mid-season finale is when they're gonna
finally pin Prometheus on a couple
people and be like here this is the
explanation this is kind of how it works
this is why Prometheus is doing what
he's doing so given all that based on
the information they presented in this
episode how do you think that Quentin is
involved in this I feel like somebody's
taking advantage of him in the
information that he has like that's
probably how Prometheus knew about the
list if it's not Quentin then somebody
pulled that information out of Quentin
when he was super drunk so either
Quentin is being mind-controlled and he
has crazy ninja skills or somebody else
is manipulating him and he doesn't
realize it because he's been getting so
drunk so just remember that they're
trying to lead you in a couple different
directions like they want you to wonder
about Felicity's boyfriend because he's
one of the people inside the police
department you know Felicity came to
that conclusion at the end of the
episode it's somebody inside the police
station but they also want you to think
about Quentin because he's like oh my
god there's blood there's a throwing
star what the hell is happening so the
other big thing Ivan Drago he-man
debuted on the show Dolph Lundgren has
this total negan introduction if you
guys don't watch Walking Dead he's just
like a really evil charismatic person
where he gives Oliver this cold speech
about how he's basically not going
anywhere and no matter how much Oliver
tries he's not going to be able to get
rid of him so that's why he says it's
going to be a pleasure working with you
because he knows the
Oliver wants to kill him get rid of him
but he's such a badass that he just
throws that in Oliver's face there's
nothing you can do about me you're just
gonna have to get used to it so he
pretty much just threw the gauntlet down
if you watch the first couple of
episodes of The Walking Dead Season
seven this year like the last couple
weeks
negan pretty much did the same thing
albeit in a much much bloodier way but
it was a great episode the soundtrack
was good I like what the other
characters are doing - there was a lot
of stuff happening but I feel like the
couple big things that happened in this
episode were so big that I wanted to
focus the video about that so let me
know in the comments do you think that
this is gonna have anything to do with
Talia al Ghul's appearance on the show
what's going on with this Prometheus
conspiracy it sounds like it might be a
couple people working together rather
than just a single person but just
remember midseason finale isn't that far
off so we're gonna get a little bit more
information every single episode but
also really good news so legends of
tomorrow this season only had a 13
episode order initially the CW just
ordered for more episodes because they
like what they're doing so much so
there's going to be 17 episodes total of
legends of tomorrow this year instead of
13 for those of you that are still
asking - the flash was on break this
week but everything is back to normal
next week it was just because of the
election because that took up most of
Tuesday night so the flash is back next
week even though the order is kind of
weird
they'll probably sync things up before
the big mid-season crossover so the
other shows might go on break a little
bit so that the flash can catch up or
they'll do something so that the flash
will be able to catch up and it'll
happen in the right order so whenever
they announce something about that I'll
totally do an update like the next big
DC video that I do but there is a new
round of the giveaway going on now I'll
announce the winner in my legends of
tomorrow video all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
so it'll engines of tomorrow posting
later tonight there was also a cool
spider-man Home Coming interview video
that I'll try to post if I can get it
out before legends of tomorrow posts now
that the election craziness is over we
can turn our attention back to the
really important stuff comic books will
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the teaser for a killer
frost vibe comic book costumes on the
flash and you can click here to learn
how Fox is rebooting their entire x-men
you
Hertz which includes Wolverine and
Deadpool so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight